salut j'ai seulement 5 secondes pour
vous rappeler que la dernière de mon
spectacle sa liberté après gratuit c'est
le 11 décembre au zénith de paris de
lire et dans la description nouvelle
vidéo salue on a tous joué un jeu de
cartes que ce soit la bataille le tarot
le poker leurs amis le jeu des 7
familles peu plus d'ailleurs on a tous
essayé de tricher un peu si je vous vois
faire vous le faites main je vous
apprendrai des techniques les jeux de
cartes sont partout il c'est le jeu de
société le plus répandu dans le monde
entier pourtant c'était mal barré au
départ les cartes ont été interdits
d'usagé pendant trois siècles par
l'église café quand vous brûlez en enfer
à cause et ensuite elles ont tellement
évolué prospérer voyager parce que oui
une carte peut voyager qu'aujourd'hui on
s'en sert même pour prédire l'avenir moi
c'est ce que prétendent les personnes
qui tire les cartes je peux d'ores et
déjà vous prédire moi justement que vous
allez tout savoir sur la carte
maintenant et je crois même que je
perçois que loïc va lancer un générique
c'est comme ça je cherchais pas cessé
les flashs ça me travers loïc gêné
[Musique]
oh
première partie le collier le judo c'est
un peu trop épique non il y a toujours
une première fois à tout alors d'où
vient le premier jeu de cartes il serait
apparu en chine cela plastique tangue
entre 700 et 900 ses premières cartes
correspondait à trois types de jeux
chinois les cartes monétaire les cartes
dominos et les cartes et chèques leur
arrivée ensuite en europe se situerait
quelques siècles plus tard on estime que
c'est au 14e siècle le consensus
s'accorde à dire qu'elle serait d'abord
arrivés en italie du nord 1440 grâce à
des échanges marchands avec les arabes
dont des asiatiques d'autres pistes sont
explorées en ce moment mais c'est pas
simple de retrouver la trace de tout ça
il n'y avait pas d'iphone à l'époque
pour filmer pour faire des petits ce
torride et regarder les roms j'ai ramené
salazie et tous et trop stylées
s'appelle un jeu de cartes bon bah on
cherche et on trouve ce qu'on peut une
chose est sûre les italiens ont très
vite adopté le jeu de cartes et l'ont
adaptée à leur culture en créant leurs
propres symboles leur jeu se divise en
quatre couleurs la coupe le bâton l'épée
et le denier ce qu'on appelle les
couleurs c'est le nom réel pour les
familles fugueurs car autres fc des
couleurs en réalité il y avait aussi ce
qu'on appelle les figures mais qui à
l'époque n'avait pas encore de nom à
titre d'exemple voici une carte on peut
imaginer qu'il s'agit d'un noble avec un
falcon ou un falcon alors on en fait
cote ces cartes bien on joue avec l'un
des premiers jeux serait celui de
l'ascopa mais à l'époque le nombre de
cartes de figure ainsi que les couleurs
étaient différentes d'une région à une
autre chacun avait sa ce copain c'est un
peu comme les jeux dans kaamelott le cul
de chouette c'est pas pareil si c'est au
pays de galles par exemple les italiens
vont par ailleurs créé le célèbre jeu le
tarot qui sera lui aussi détourné et qui
sera adoptée par d'autres pays comme la
france le tas reconnaîtra par la suite
un second emploi dans les sciences
occultes mais ça j'y reviendrai plus
tard puis il faudra attendre la fin du
14ème siècle et le début du xvème pour
voir les cartes à jouer arriver vraiment
en france et laissez-moi vous dire
qu'elles sont pas passées inaperçues
genre un truc de ouf c'était un peu le
squeeze game du 14e siècle sauf qu'on
s'en sortait vivant et encore ça dépend
ce qu'on avait parié il y avait
tellement de demandes que ça fait naître
des nouveaux métiers comme les tailleurs
de moules de cartes les imprimeurs de
cartes à jouer qu'on appelait les
quartiers dont le premier serait apparue
à lui en 1444 les quartiers apportent
leurs propres symboles tout en gardant
les dix cartes numéral allant de l'ass
au 10 mai il ya toujours
face à l'emballement général il ya
quelqu'un il commence à diane hep hep
hep qu'est ce que vous faites là quand
vous arrêtez ça tout de suite pourquoi
pas parce qu'on touche pas d'argent
dessus mais on va leur dire que c'est
pour sauver leur âme damnée il s'agit
bien de l'église et des autorités
civiles à l'époque l'église n'aimait pas
franchement les jeux divertissants
c'était un peu el diablo le jeu déjà par
ailleurs interdit pourquoi parce que la
population soldats avaient la fâcheuse
habitude de jouer de l'argent et ça
c'est diabolique à l'époque pas le fait
de jouer de l'argent est plutôt que sept
moulins ne soient contrôlés ni par
l'état ni par l'église c'est ça hein le
vrai problème au final l'église décide
donc d'interdire l'usagé des cartes à
tous les religieux sous prétexte qu'elle
était contraire à l'usagé modéré des
patients les croyants avaient donc
l'interdiction formelle d'y jouer et ça
jusqu'au xviie siècle 300 ans sans même
se taper une petite belote coinchée
comme ça au comptoir l'annonçant à coeur
on aurait pu se dire qu'avec tout ça le
joueur aurait pu disparaître me l'a pas
complètement disparu c'est au xvème
siècle les français inventeur famille
que vous connaissez bref car au coeur
épique ce sont également les français
qui ont donné un nom aux premières
figures qui sont le roi la dame elle
valait faut savoir que dans certains
jeux on pouvait trouver jusqu'à 16
figures dont le roi la reine le valais
et le cavalier mais il ya toujours on a
2 mai lorsque la révolution française a
sonné et que louis c'est ainsi que sa
cour ont été
il était plutôt malvenu de continuer à
jouer avec des cartes qu'ils portaient
quand même les noms royaux les
dénominations rois et reines en
l'occurrence faisait un peu mauvais
genre quand même et pas très
révolutionnaire mais vous l'avez
peut-être compris aussi les cartes ne
servait pas seulement que à jouer à d
autres usages des cartes à jouer et ça
ça m'a bluffé le jour j'ai découvert ça
c'est en rapport avec le fait que le
papier était une denrée rare jusqu'au
début du 19ème et comme le taux des
cartes étaient blancs à défaut de jouer
avec notamment durant les trois siècles
où l'église en interdisent l usage elles
ont une seconde vie on en profitait pour
glisser des mots doux derrière faire des
certificats de mariage mais aussi des
cartes de visite des reconnaissances de
dettes d ordre d'incarcération
on s'en servait comme du papier les
cartes ont également servi de monnaie au
cours de la révolution française grâce à
cette seconde vie on a pu aussi
retrouver notre époque à nous des notes
de molière de napoléon de rousseau des
listes d'invités de louis saez
directement écrites sur des cartes à
jouer en prêt c'est complètement fou il
semblerait que les double tête sur les
cartes en dessins étaient destinés aux
alentours de 1830 afin qu'on n'ait plus
à retourner les art pour les remettre
dans le bon sens et c'est en 1858 que
baptiste paul grimault introduit en
france les coins arrondis afin que ne se
tourne pas et qu'on triche un petit peu
moins encore dans le coin des cartes
justement pour savoir ce que l'autre il
a en main doit faire comment il a su que
j'avais 4 aschbach garde il a plié les
points c'était peau dure baptiste paul
grimault sera par ailleurs le fondateur
de la plus grande maison de quartier de
l'époque et c'est entre autres dans son
atelier que sera créé le célèbre tarot
de marseille
le taureau j'ai un chat dans la gorge
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que le
tarot était né en italie du nord philip
marris visconti duc de milan et férus de
jeux de stratégie aurait commandé verte
1415 un jeu de cartes un marc diallo des
tortona un humaniste milanais rappelez
vous qu'à l'époque il était composé de
56 kg en quatre couleurs tout bâton et
denis mais sans 1440 qu'on lui aurait
donné le nom de cartes d'être créée en
fit triompher ça signifie triomphe en
france est vraiment il ya un bon indice
est facile cet adjectif est apparu quand
une série de 22 cartes est venu
s'ajouter aux 56 carte initiale n'y
avait pas assez de cartes apparemment
cette série rajouter est appelé par les
joueurs les atouts mais d'autres les
appels des arcanes ou bien les lames et
ce sont les ésotériques karoui de tarot
est par la suite devenu le jeu d'arts
divinatoires le plus répandu à travers
le monde mais ça j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure et c'est assez hallucinant
toutefois cette nouvelle série ajouté
représenter une innovation majeure d'où
le terme triomphe le motard au 8
viendrai de la tare de la balance dans
les règles du tarot on doit en effet
déduire certaines cartes avant de jouer
donc on doit faire la balance
mentalement ce qui a donné ta roig dans
le dialecte italiens puis tarot en
français alors genk le jeu est
rapidement traverser les frontières de
l'europe ce n'est qu'entre le xviie et
xviiie siècles et qu'il est
véritablement répandue et qui la
trouvent un large public en france et en
allemagne néanmoins il n'était pas aussi
populaire qu'aujourd'hui ce jeu était
destiné aux élites et non au petit
peuple comme il disait à cause de sa
complexité de règles et de la mémoire
que sa demande et pour pouvoir y jouer
rebaptisée par la suite le star aux
italiens par les français plusieurs
versions ont été créées par les
quartiers bien qu'il se reposait
majoritairement sur les symboles et les
enseignes latine les quartiers se sont
malgré tout approprié le jeu en créant à
leur tour leurs propres symboles figurer
couleurs bref à chaque fois les gars ils
peuvent pas s'empêcher de changer des
trucs en faisant passer la main un
soldat
non on avait dignement michel le plus
ancien jeu français de tarot qu'on a
retrouvé c'est celui des 4 nages au
froid à lyon en 1557 il était composé de
seulement 38 carte au 17e le tarot de
paris issue d'un anonyme ce policier
avait su trouver sa place tout comme les
tarots de jean noblet de jacques vié
touvier biéville janvier dernier ville
mais c'est viéville aussi de tarot
italien héros baptisé en 1680 le tarot
de besançon vraiment tout ça de la gêne
les deux sens à chaque fois les mecs qui
font ce qu'ils veulent et enfin on y
arrive le tarot de nicolas converse un
célèbre quartier situé à marseille sera
décisive dans l'histoire de ce jeu jean
baptiste qu'à moi a racheté la boutique
de nicolas converse et a créé son propre
tarot en 1860 il baptisera sa version de
jeu le tarot de marseille alors est-ce
que c'est lui l'auteur du célèbre tarot
de marseille ou mais non mais oui quand
même un peu non aussi en résumé pas
vraiment mais un peu quand même on est
en 1900 lorsque l'administration
française demande à la maison grimaud le
plus célèbre quartier français de créa
un tarot nouveau pôle marteau le petit
nouveau le successeur de baptiste paul
grimault et à la tête de la maison
grimaud paul marteau décide donc de
créer le tarot nous y va rien inventer
pour faire ça il va s'inspirer du tarot
de besançon mais aussi de celui de
jean-baptiste cas - le quartier
marseillais si bien que paul marteau l'a
rebaptisé en 1930 l'ancien tarot de
marseille et puis commercialement on se
dit que si ses anciens c'est que c'est
bien quoi parce que ça a l'air vrai quoi
il alors comment un jeu ludique a pu
devenir un outil censé lire les pages
cachées du présent mais aussi pouvoir
avec ces mêmes car prédire l'avenir le
tarot un art divinatoire
son usage divinatoires a émergé en 1770
on a retrouvé la première trace de son
usage au culte en provence où une femme
affirmé pouvoir retrouver des objets
perdus en consultant son tarot et de ce
fait elle a été arrêtée et mise au
carcan avec une couronne de tarot sur la
tête et on lui a fait un nom aux
hérétiques pas facile à cette époque où
même moment un occultistes français
jean-baptiste aliette nommé et l ia
publie le tout premier manuel de
cartomancie du monde qu'il baptise
cartomancie égyptienne parce qu'on met
toujours une destination il a notamment
repris une théorie d'antoine cours de
jets de l'iaas avant érudit francs
maçons qui a écrit de nombreuses
hypothèses sur la signification au culte
des symboles retrouver dans le tarot oui
parce que si vous regardez bien les
arcanes majeurs sont bourrés de petits
symboles et laisse place à de multiples
interprétations quoi qu'il en soit ces
corps de jeu blanc lui-même qui aurait
initié et elia à la lecture de ces
cartes de là et elle il ya publiera un
livre qui s'appelle manière de se
recréer avec le jeu de carte nommée
d'art ou alors lusage divinatoires va
connaître un essor énorme au milieu du
19e avec deux personnes alphonse ou mais
constant ecclésiastique français qui
sera qualifié de grand rénovateur de
l'occultisme français par son biographe
et qui jouera un rôle majeur dans la
diffusion de cette pratique et gérard
encausse appelé papus un médecin et
occultistes qui participera également à
l'expansion internationale du tarot
divinatoire
grâce à ces ouvrages tels que le carreau
des bohémiens selon moi n'y a pas de
ville parce que les bohémiens ça voyage
et pour quelles raisons le tarot ou
encore l'ancien tarot de marseille a
suscité ce second emploi ce sont les 22
arcanes majeurs qui soulève tant de
questionnements et d'hypothèses occulte
celle ci décrivent tout d'abord un
parcours dans le monde terrestre avec la
carte du bateleur du marchand ou encore
les couples du pape et de la papesse
ainsi que l'empereur et l'impératrice
mais en plus de ça il ya les
vicissitudes de la vie humaine avec le
chariot la justice lamoureux ou encore
la mort ou le diable pour enfin
s'achever par un chemin dit de lumière
avec l'étoile la lune et le soleil cet
ensemble débouche ensuite sur le monde
et le jugement bref vous l'aurez compris
d'anciens tarot de marseille est une
histoire que l'on peut adapter une
personne pour lui raconter des choses on
peut aussi retrouver deux célèbres
voyant qu'ils avaient pour outils des
jeux de divination allant du tarot de
marseille à l'astrologie marcel beline
le célèbre médium du xxème siècle
prédira le lancement de spoutnik la
découverte vaccin antipolio le naufrage
de l'andrea doria mais aussi la mort de
marilyn monroe ou encore jeanne dixon
célèbre astrologue du xxème siècle
également et sans doute la plus
influente qui a prédit l'assassinât de
kennedy mais aussi celui de gandhi et de
martin luther king mais au final quand
on réfléchit un peu ces prédictions ne
sont elles pas des interprétations a
posteriori car une fois l'événement
passé ou plus simplement dans la masse
des prédictions qui sont faites chaque
jour à ce que c'est pas logique que de
temps en temps on est quand même
quelques unes qui tombe juste d'ailleurs
attention mais après la pluie il y en a
le beau temps à mon sens cela c'est
personnel je me dis que l'interprétation
des prédictions pourrait faire une vidéo
intéressante un jour vous en pensez quoi
on pourrait se plonger dans nostradamus
jusqu'à nos jours et on pourrait voir
tout ce qui colle en fait mais même on
se dit on prend les prédictions de
nostradamus et on compare avec le
youtube game actuelle et en voici
nostradamus avait prédit l'essor de view
tube tik tok je suis sûr que parfois on
peut raccorder des choses si ça vous
tente vous me dites un petit peu dans
les commentaires ne pensez pas que je
veux que des commentaires pour la gauche
ça c'est très cool hein pour la lgo je
dis pas le contraire mais quand je
demande ça c'est pour avoir une tendance
un petit peu voire proportionnellement
qui s'exprime pas sur le sujet ok si
vous voulez aller plus loin d'ailleurs
sur le sujet des cartes etc c'est pas
hasard que j'en parle aujourd'hui c'est
que le prochain curieuse celui qui va
paraître le mois prochain va traiter
entre autres de tout ça c'est grâce
entre autres au travail des journalistes
qu'on a pu monter un dossier complet que
vous allez retrouver dans curieuse si
vous ne connaissez pas mon magazine que
ryu c'est un magazine mensuel de 60 plus
de 60 pages 62 pages pour être précis au
début on faisait 40 maintenant il a
grossi fait 60 c'est un flux mensuel
c'est à dire 7 10 numéros par an parce
que juillet et août c'est le même numéro
et décembre janvier également vous avez
un bien dans la description vers le site
curieuse point fr ça répond à toutes vos
questions vous trouvez les abonnements
au magazine si vous voulez au numéro si
vous voulez vous abonner pour
l'abonnement ses 29 90 par an pour un
nombre magazine 62 pages à chaque fois
frais de port inclus et puis vous
retrouverez des choses en plus ce genre
les hors séries une boutique avec les
t-shirts que je suis en train de porter
d'ailleurs vous avez tout ça dans la
description on est à dix neuf numéros
c'est une grande fierté merci à ceux qui
sont déjà abonnés étant que j'ai votre
attention attention justement un c'est
bientôt la fin de mon spectacle
singularité il ne sera plus jouer là je
vous dis les dates du mois de novembre
je suis à liège à bruxelles c'est déjà
complet à rome c'est déjà complet au
havre à saint benoît à lyon à saint
grégoire c'est déjà complet à nantes à
bourges à boisseuil à besançon et puis
bien sûr les deux grandes dernière à la
rochelle et au zénith de paris une
grosse surprise au zénith n'hésitez pas
à venir sur quelques unes de ces dates
parce qu'après c'est terminé pour ce
spectacle lien dans la description moi
je vous donne rendez vous vendredi
prochain pour la nouvelle vidéo c'est un
concept interactif un truc a jamais été
fait donc rendez-vous vraiment au
vendredi à 18h sur la chaîne et si je
vous mets deux autres vidéos qui sont
parus récemment ça c'est un casse-tête à
la tesla c'est génial est juste là je
vous mets une fiction première fiction
de youtube en plus vous allez vous
creuser la tête prenez soin de vous et à
très bientôt
ciao